is it for you time to part of this
conservation feel incredibly important
and I really really don't want to see
the Rhinos being extinct I think they're
incredibly part of Africa I just I love
them so much and I think it'd be such a
shame the season lost everywhere you
look you see rhinos it's great and this
being here has this emphasize to you how
much in danger how vulnerable they are
yeah incredibly you see how many babies
we've got here and there's probably we
go nose around Kruger that need our help
and you know it's just so important to
help him and what about the urgency of
the whole campaign because this is the
figures are getting worse you put in the
wash you in here the latest figures came
out and made it so that there was a
30-percent nearly thirty percent
increase in poaching despite the
increased efforts to stop it have you
had a sense of how urgent o death
situation is tell us about what your
thought m-miss you know as I said you
know there's so many babies here and I
you know it's just terrible they they
definitely need more places like this i
think around South Africa to help the
babies and I also feel new person have
made a difference oh yeah definitely I
think as a team collectively I think
we've all made a massive difference you
know getting up it 2 a.m. to do night
feeds and you know doing this every
morning feeding them throughout the day
it's lots of hard work but is so
rewarding you know you actually feel
like you you're helping the babies